[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to this
majestic event the USA versus the rest
of the world it is indeed the first of
its kind I had to ask Tony rich three
times is it really the first time that
this has ever happened and indeed he's
confirmed a team event with the best
young US players against the best young
world players a fine cast indeed and
happening here in st. Louis the capital
of chess in the United States
I'm Maurice Ashley and of course I'm
thrilled that we're gonna be able to do
commentary on this event and we've put
together a great cast of course we have
fantastic officials here today including
one special player who's done something
like this before in his life we will get
to him in a moment but before we do that
let us introduce the players of course
the road team always goes first
they are capped in the world team by
espacio brevis Alexander belli offski
and the head of the delegation for hey
Vega and to the players themselves
representing feed a women's FM new Gil
Sally mola
and representing Russia the under-14
girls
Bibi sorrow sob Ava and for the under 14
boys representing India Fragonard
Animesh Babu International Master by the
way apologies representing us Becca Stan
International Master navour nadir Vic
I'm gonna get this right nadir big I'd
posit are off and now for the under-17
boys representing Russia FM Andre essa
Benko from India Grandmaster Aryan
Chopra from Armenia International Master
high eke a Martirosyan from Russia
grandmaster Alexi Serena and finally
from Australia international master
anton smirnov they will be stiff
competition
indeed they look like they have their
game faces on area to play chess the US
team is gonna have to be ready but we do
have a fine cast young u.s. players will
be getting stronger and stronger every
single year they are captained by
Michael Khodorkovsky arm in arm but sue
Mian and the team coach is Alexander
honest truth Grand Master himself for
the under 14 girls women's fm
Martha summer - Billie
and also women's fm charisa yep
the under 14 boys candidate master
Andrew ha and Grandmaster elect a wonder
Liang and for the under-17 boys
I believe it's international master
Nicholas yes sorry
international master Nicholas Jacob
[Applause]
international master John Burke grand
master roofing Li grand master Sam
Savion and headed by the world junior
champion grand master Geoffrey Zhang
they will be playing some intense games
and matches over the next few days for
days in fact the games will begin at
10:10 a.m. that is 10 a.m. Central time
starting tomorrow
well we also have a cast of characters
on stage now some very lustrous people
it will be delegated overseeing
everything International arbiter Francis
Frank Guadalupe and Frank I know you
just had a 50th anniversary so grand
graduated fifty years thirty only 30th
anniversary with his wife congratulate
Franklin thirty years of marriage
[Applause]
we also have Jeanne Hoffman of the US
Chess Federation heading the USS
Federation she unfortunately is retiring
so I want to say his who said that so
much but I want to get to the questions
as we go with each player so I'm going
to first introduce our host of the event
someone who really needs no introduction
without him this event simply would not
occur and all the many wonderful events
here in st. Louis he and his wife have
been extraordinary benefactors for chess
in st. Louis has simply transformed
chess in United States and we're ever
grateful to the man and the personal
friend Rex Sinquefield thank thank you
very much Maurice I want to welcome all
of our international players it's
probably your first time to st. Louis
and I certainly hope it is not your last
now when Maurice said a man who needs no
introduction you realize that is a
euphemism for saying the less said the
better sorry I thought that was
extremely clever very funny I judge the
intelligence of my audience by how they
respond to my humor
okay now you're on notice so well I'll
tell you it's really it's incredibly
exciting and I have to tell the foreign
visitors you have no way of knowing this
but the press that we have received
throughout the United States on this
event is amazing you have already become
the United States celebrities and you
have let yet to play a game here that's
quite an accomplishment so we're looking
forward to some incredible exciting
chests over the next four days this is
our first event partnering with feed a
u.s. chess and the Kasparov chess
foundation and we're very proud of it
all of us share a common goal of
promoting scholastic and professional
chess and we know that today we are
looking at our junior stars and the
future stars of the chess world and that
is a wonderful thing
here in st. Louis we have we've been in
more than 100 classrooms have served
over 24,000 students since we've opened
in 2008 it's hard to believe it's that
long ago it feels like yesterday we've
hosted the u.s. championship the Women's
Championship the Junior Championship
over the past nine years and this will
be a fifth year that the club will be
hosting the Sinquefield become a title
for which I was opposed but you know I
don't have much say here so we
appreciate everyone's support and we
hope that you enjoy st. Louis as much as
we do and I hope you get to see it and
whoever wins this tournament I'm going
to give you the st. Louis Arch Thank You
Rex always under promises and
over-deliver Slater well Frank let's get
to you first
you've been around chess for about a
hundred years just shooting the number
obviously you know I love you we can
make fun of each other well as director
of chess events in the US you've seen an
incredible resurgence of talent here in
the United States winning US cadets
world juniors
all these titles what does it say about
what's going on this miracle in u.s.
chess right now well first of all I
think it says that the best is you have
to come we're doing great I remember
looking at some of the u.s. players
Jeffrey he played in one of my
tournaments when he was just getting
started I think he was about seven years
old and here he is a Grand Master same
thing was do friendly
I saw stem as a young player as well so
it's amazing that these players who I
saw and knew when they were seven eight
years old
here they are grandmasters and I'm sure
that the same story holds true for
players outside the US these young
players who are amazing players so I
think we're in very good shape it's
gonna get better I'm looking forward to
hopefully God willing seen Olympiad or a
lot of these players are going to
for sending us I think we're in very
good shape both of the boys and the
girls
Jen you're the you you're the head of
yours Ches the time you came to now it's
like night and day it's absolutely
incredible but your feelings about this
miracle happening in the United States
which s you know it's so exciting this
event is just one of the many ways that
chess history is being made here in the
United States and we're really honored
to welcome these top players from
throughout the world and show them this
chest capital but there's a lot going on
it's really exciting
absolutely Jorge Vega is the continental
credit president to feed a of the
Americas or hey you've been around chess
for a couple of years at least what is
your feeling about the development of
chess in the Americas and as you watch
these very young players mean seeing
grandmasters at this age was impossible
30 years ago just about impossible and
now it's pretty routine to see a
grandmaster at 14 13 shrug your
shoulders but for us for us we've been
around a while it's pretty amazing
well before I amateur
I want to apologize on behalf of Richard
macropolis feel an impression that was
supposed to be here have replaced me but
unfortunately he lost the connection
second I have to apologize because my
English however I shall tell you I
believe that they well for me firstly
Tejano to be here in San Luis it is a
Luis chess club which is the heart of
the case in the USA it is the first
second I believe that the humans have a
very serious impact not only in America
but in the world world it opens a lot of
possibility of mutual cooperation
between
the USA and the rest of the world and of
course I am sure that there will be a
check a benchmark and even that is the
beginning of what was in the past the
matches between USA against the world
Soviet Union against the world all of
these that made a big impact in addition
I believe that was an excellent idea
and I want to sight-read agree but the
parajets foundation and especially with
the centerfold that have injected a new
energy in the USA yeah Cindy thank you
so much for those words I promise the
grievous this is a very important event
and I know you've taken this job quite
seriously how does how was your team
formed and what did you do in
preparation for this event well mostly
it was not so difficult to select the
best in my opinion engineers nowadays in
the world we study their games in the
trainer's Commission repeated various
Commission mean magician who is not here
now and of course it was not only meter
code but all of these kids of course
they have their own trainers which they
helped learn Lots
and we should always think about it and
they're ready and I think we're good and
Michael Karkov ski who has been a part
of young teams and captain and young
teams for the US you didn't look like
you had hard choices here it looked like
you probably could sit back and just
make the rating list through the rest
but you had to prepare somewhat so tell
us a little bit about the preparation
for getting your team ready for this
match yes very easy choice
because we have in the u.s. quite
democratic tradition to select any team
by rating so therefore it was very easy
to select in terms of preparation most
of them are members of the program young
start team USA which supported in
collaboration of Kasparov chess
foundation and Santa Lucia's Club and
scholastic Center and I would like to
recognize head coach of this program
Grandmaster Alexander journey many other
coaches who helped throughout the years
that this program six years and we look
forward for good results going forward
and to see the total day one of our
stars will become the world champion
thank you well gentlemen who was a
pretty decent player as a child he was
okay
went on to do some big things of course
needs no introduction but I always loved
talking about him because he's such an
inspiration to me personally as a player
watching his games when I was coming up
really inspired me to become a fairly
decent player of myself but clearly
nowhere near his ranks please everyone a
big hand for the 13th world champion of
chess Garry Kasparov
and gallery if I may before you say any
words I'd like to lead with a question
you were part of the USSR versus the
world team you've been a part of team
events when you look at this these young
faces very young faces in some cases
what's your feeling going back your
memories and what is give us a sense of
what this kind of event would be like my
memory is going all the way back to 1970
I was seven
and we all were watching the first match
the USSR versus the rest of the world by
the way I was quite in a quite a fight
so the expected Soviet team to win
easily credit to the country that was
very close and in 1984 when where the
second match I was really part of the
service quote playing war ii against
young t1 so we won again and then it was
another match in rapid interrupted
Russia versus the rest of the world
which was from worst performance ever
and it was a - result that's not the
brightest memories but I would say that
this event it's it's sort of it's as mr.
Becker said it's it's a benchmark first
of all it shows the results that we
achieved here in the United States now
that the United States can take on the
rest of the wall of course nobody knows
we'd win but still it's we have to
weaken squats in Springs and we have
some great young talents here that's
it's very important because itself it's
a 50th anniversary of the sport of just
foundation that their form was Michael
in 2002 here and it's also it's a it's a
justification of the work that we did
for the Rising Stars thanks to very
generous support from various entities
in folks in whose chest clapping and
scholastics and now we have a team and
it was very important that we they
actually agreed to play along and to
join us within these efforts and I feel
really good about it because I don't
think there's any other city in the
world that that has so many
important tournaments in the world like
set loose we all know that San Luis is
the chest capital of United States and I
would say it's another step that was the
bid to become the chest capital of the
world and having the young talents it's
it's again it's the to move in this
direction as you said they wished some
of the young players from the rest of
the wall team they they might be coming
back here which means they'll become
very good players because the best tools
in the world taking place here and I
think it's best symbolic that just at
the end of this tournament will start
another Grantchester event with all the
best players in the world including
world champion Magnus Carlsen and I feel
really good about it it's just it's a
place where many old chess traditions
have been preserved and as I said it's
the only place where I feel comfortable
playing chess going along with that I
would be remiss if I didn't mention it
because I throw a lot of viewers are
intrigued by this you're inspired what's
the inspiration for you making a
comeback in a couple of weeks we're all
looking for this comeback we lost five
days very sure it's because it's a dregs
because the atmosphere and I just said I
fell that will be very important to help
to promote to promote the spirit of San
Luis the great the great chess capital
wall and also again it's it's it's a
part of this of this of the Serie so it
would be last event on these three and
again that's symbolic we have young
players and followed by by the best in
the world and then it will be like you
know this the the cherry on the top of
the torso the the Rapidan boots I
thought you're gonna say the old players
so my my performance would be not to
disappoint people too much and I am I
welcome the the rest of the wall to you
and I think it's again it's it's it's a
beginning it's a beginning of a new
relationship
with with the world just organization
and I of course I I will be rooting
throughout him that's because we have
been working so hard to make this team
strong but it will be a great event and
the eyes of the world it will be will be
at st. Louis and I said lose chess club
and I just hope that itself we are here
today setting up just new tradition well
we appreciate your spirit your vision
and the hard work you put in ever ladies
and gentlemen the comeback kid former
world champion Garry Kasparov and we
have an official who's the executive
director of the Chess Club is classic
Center st. Louis who will share with us
a few words on the format of this first
of a kind tournament please welcome Tony
rich
[Applause]
hi everyone and welcome so that the
format of this turbine is actually very
straightforward think of it as a
tournament in two sections the top
section which is the under
seventeen-year-olds will be playing
what's called a Scheveningen style chess
tournament so Scheveningen is basically
like a round-robin where everybody plays
everybody else except it's for team
events so every team member of the
under-17 US team will face every team
member of the world under-17 section and
vice versa now in the under 14 section
think of it as mini matches so there are
four boys - USA - world and there are
four girls - USA - world each of them
will play two game matches against the
other so the the boys on the under 14
section on USA team will play two games
against each of the under 14 boys from
the world team the idea of this
tournament is basically to obviously
spotlight these young players and
promote what they're doing here but
ultimately whichever team comes out
victorious combined score between the
under-17 section in the under 14 section
will be the winner of the match
Millennials fantastic well it's time to
do the paperwork that's right the
drawing up the lots okay so drawing of
the lots will be done with these
wonderful baseballs FBI over here so
underneath these pieces of paper on each
baseball's either a white king or a
black King and that will determine the
color order in which all the players
face each other now again since this is
Scheveningen in matches everybody plays
everybody so we don't have to worry
about pairing numbers or anything like
that but just the color and the order in
which they'll play each other so
Grandmaster grievous as the captain of
the under-17 section if you could pick
one of these two for me that one okay
let's check it out
okay so Grand Master Grievous has
selected the white pieces which means
they'll play white on board one in the
under-17 section and Michael this one
would be for you just to make sure I'm
honest there's a black King under there
alright and these are baseball signed by
st. Louis Cardinals baseball manager
Mike Matheny who's actually a spokesman
for the Chess Club in scholastic center
of st. Louis and he's been a great
partner with us as well okay for the
under 14 sections would you guys like to
draw again are you would you like your
your team captains or hey Vega it's the
head of delegation for the world team if
you would do the honors no cheating okay
and they get the white pieces on the
under 14 section two and once again we
have the black pieces for the USA team
so that means that tomorrow the world
team will start with the white pieces on
board one for the under-17 section and
they'll start with the white pieces on
the under 14 section and then we
alternate colors from there everybody
okay fantastic well this will be indeed
an epic one-of-a-kind first-of-a-kind
event we hope to see many more of course
but to have these illustrious young
players here in the u.s. joining the
squad that is in the US already
competing against each other in a match
that will be washed around the world
we're going to all have a good time with
your great commentary team Jennifer
Shahadah and also Alejandro Ramirez will
be joining me
so everyone make sure you check us out
at 10 minutes to 10:00 central time
tomorrow you'll see us talking about
these great games from these great young
players don't want to miss it once again
thank thank you all the officials who
are part of this event everyone who made
this event happen
certainly
and all the young players who were here
everyone will see you tomorrow thank you
very much and have a great night
[Applause]